well with us now are John Davison he's
am G internationals director for Europe
and Central Asia and Jason Packers
research into Middle Eastern history at
Cambridge University and president of
the Libya analysis comma government
consultancy on living policy welcome to
you both John first of all one gets the
sense that everyone is horrified about
this yet there is not the political will
to stop it happening element we've seen
the beginning of a change of that this
afternoon with the announcement from
from Aubrey that we just saw after the
meeting foreign ministers in in
Luxembourg I think the horror has
reached such a significant scale after
after months of denial and obfuscation
that it's got to the point where the EU
and and national leaders realize they
have to do something and the commitments
that are coming out of Luxembourg today
arlys going in the right direction more
search and rescue assets operating
closer to Libya ensures with more
funding will national state governments
follow up with the necessary assets and
commitments themselves that's what we'll
have to see in the come what is
happening to the four hundred thousand
or so people who have made it now we
understand across the Mediterranean well
they're being the 400,000 that have made
it from Africa into well that's over
quite a large period of yeah I or
obviously I mean of the I'm sorry
thousands that have been entered in the
in the last few few weeks they're in
reception centers in distributed mostly
around around Italy what will happen to
to them it will depend very much on the
on their situation the refugees the bona
fide asylum seekers one hopes will get
access to to assign them quickly others
will be sent back others will not be
sent back because of obstacles to doing
that doesn't you see the problems being
fundamentally in North Africa and indeed
sub-saharan Africa yes I'm afraid that
the European policy response will be
fundamentally one of treating the
symptom rather than treating the cause
yes there are all these migrants who are
facing humanitarian catastrophes and
crossing the Med but the issue is that
we have a civil war in Libya that
the EU and Western countries have
focused on what I'm contributed to and I
don't believe contributed to but have
focused on treating the symptoms rather
than having a plan B for the fact that
Bernardino Leon's mediation mission is
not the only approach and the fact is
the longer the war continues the more
that each militia needs to gain assets
from smuggling heroin smuggling
subsidized petrol and of course
smuggling migrants who are a huge source
of cash particularly for the Miss rotten
malicious but also present and other
malicious and we need to see this
tragedy and go to the root cause which
is the Libyan Civil War invest political
as well as monetary assets to treating
that root cause and then there won't be
a need to deal with this issue I mean
the problem as I understand it is that
no one can really operate in Libya along
with Libyan coast at the moment because
of the state of possibilities that well
it's manifested in case that the Libyan
authorities such as there are are
totally incapable of offering any kind
of search and rescue services in their
own search and rescue zone I think more
broadly there's obviously a complete
impossibility of any kind of meaningful
cooperation with any authority that
there is there now but I mean I would
point to the fact that the push factors
driving migrants to take this route I'm
not limited to Libya alone there are
Syrian refugees who are fed up in
refugee camps closer to Syria they're
sub-saharan migrants we're coming not
necessarily refugees I mean even more
may well be that there are also
continuing to come so the push factors
are not limited to the chaos in Libya
there they are certainly being
aggravated by it is it possible to have
some kind of naval operation at either
end either a rescue operation at this
end or indeed a naval operation along
the coast of North Africa to read people
leaving I'm of the believer that there
is no sovereignty in Libya at present
and we're dealing with a country that is
terra nullius neither the truck
government nor the Tripoli government
can really be said to be the Libyan in
that case it wouldn't be faithful to
deploy enabled no I look at the exact
opposite I'm so
it means that naval assets which embargo
the country and make it impossible to
transact any sort of business are well
within the interpretation of the UN
resolution to 174 and could be things
that we could angle for and they could
deal with both things like oil smuggling
as well as the migrant issue but it
takes a international consensus between
Britain Italy France and other allies
that's why the opinion is meeting
presumably right but they're treating
the symptom and not the cause because we
need to link anything that we're doing
about the migrant issue to creating
incentives and disincentives for Tobruk
and Tripoli so that they're going to
want to make a deal and cutting them off
from the shipments of furniture and used
cars that they need to enjoy themselves
and fun Civil War would be the first
step towards treating this problem no it
out I I daresay would but I think there
are two things I mean there's a fire
burning in Libya that is for sure but
whilst you're waiting to put out the
fire you can't ignore the people jumping
out of the window and I mean that is the
point with search and rescue services in
the central Mediterranean and it is
possible and I hope it will now be the
case that the EU and its member states
can deploy meaningful search and rescue
assets much closer to the Libyan
territorial waters where they're
currently drowning in record numbers I
mean you you seem to have taken aback
when I quoted that figure four hundred
thousand that was what a mep was quoting
me today as the the number of people
that she thought be coming in this year
and the ministers meeting that I have
talked about repatriating those people
or take altered sending them back to
Africa some how quickly do you think
that's possible well I mean politicians
always talk about sending back I mean
the question is who you're sending back
and then how possible it is to do it
where you're saying but the bona fide II
asylum seeker in fact the very
significant number of those making this
journey or shouldn't be sent back at all
there those who have had an asylum claim
looked at and rejected with all the
necessary guarantees can be sent back
what do you think can be done about this
immediate crisis of people coming across
in unseaworthy boats and drowning we
don't have a plan B as a Western
community we've put ever
into Bernadina lay on the UN special
envoys mission to mediate between Tobruk
and Tripoli and yet we have nothing to
do with the negotiations fail we
absolutely need to box Egypt out on the
one side and Qatar and Turkey on the
other and deescalate the libyan civil
war by preventing the flow of armaments
and monies that drive it the reason in
which these migrants are going in record
numbers to cross the med is because the
different militias smuggle heroin
migrants and opium equally and therefore
they use that to gain money to fight the
civil war if we could treat the civil
war we would have far less migrant okay
thank you very much indeed